imaginemos que ustedes y yo estamos
jugando un juego para ver quién lanza
más rápido una pelota para esto vamos a
necesitar una pelota más o menos así y
un cronómetro que haré mi mejor esfuerzo
por dibujarlo un cronómetro
para marcar el tiempo que la pelota pase
en el aire entonces lo que hacemos es
que cuando uno lanza la pelota hacia
arriba en otra va a tomar el tiempo que
dura la pelota en el aire y vamos a usar
ese tiempo para calcular la rapidez con
la que se lanzó la pelota hacia arriba
vamos a asumir aquí y en los siguientes
vídeos sobre el movimiento de
proyectiles que no tenemos resistencia
al aire que es la resistencia del aire o
la resistencia del aire resistencia
resistencia
al aire
es nula es decir casi no hay no existe
resistencia al aire
y bueno
entonces vamos a ver el tiempo que dure
la pelota en el aire pues va a ser el
tiempo que le tome a la pelota a subir
desde que la lanzamos hasta caer y si
recordamos de nuestro vídeo anterior
esta es la gráfica del desplazamiento de
la pelota entonces lo que va a ser si no
tenemos resistencia al aire es que en el
periodo de tiempo que le dura aunque me
dura la pelota en el aire la mitad de
ese periodo de tiempo es lo que le va a
llevar a la pelota a subir y llegar
hasta el punto máximo detenerse antes de
volver a bajar así que el tiempo vamos a
escribirlo aquí
el tiempo
que le toma la pelota a subir va a ser
igual al tiempo
que le toma a la pelota bajas
entonces
bueno vamos a imaginar o vamos a tener
ya unos o imaginaron los números más
concretos vamos a decir que nuestra
pelota este duro en el aire
el cambio en el tiempo de la pelota fue
igual a 5 segundos cómo voy a calcular
la rapidez con la que lancé la pelota
bueno con esto de que el tiempo hacia
arriba es igual al tiempo hacia abajo
que tardé más en viajar en bajar perdón
vamos a ver que el cambio del tiempo
hacia arriba o el tiempo que duró la
pelota subiendo es igual a la mitad de
este periodo que va a ser 2.5 segundos
y durante este tiempo estos 2.5 segundos
fuimos de una velocidad inicial no sé
cuál fue mi velocidad inicial una
velocidad inicial pero lo que sí sé es
que llego a una velocidad final d
00 metros sobre segundo subió la pelota
llegó hasta su altura máxima y aquí se
detiene queda estaciona en el momento y
empieza a descender por eso es que la
velocidad final en este periodo de
tiempo que es la mitad del tiempo total
que estuvo la pelota en el aire la
velocidad final es cero por esta razón
entonces también conocemos que la
aceleración de la gravedad
sobre la superficie de la tierra la
aceleración de la gravedad es igual a
menos 9.8 metros sobre segundo y aquí
les recuerdo este - me está indicando la
dirección de este vector aceleración
nuestra convención era que todas las
cantidades o los vectores cuya dirección
es hacia arriba se iban a representar
con cantidades positivas y los vectores
que fueran en dirección hacia abajo se
representaría su dirección con un
símbolo negativo como la aceleración de
la gravedad va hacia abajo por eso es
que ponemos este - para indicar su
dirección y también tenemos o conocemos
otra fórmula sabemos que el cambio en el
velocidad de la velocidad
es igual a nuestra velocidad final menos
nuestra velocidad inicial
voy a cambiar otro color para que se
note un poco la diferencia entre cada
uno de esos términos el cambio en
velocidad
es la diferencia entre una nuestra
velocidad final y nuestra velocidad
inicial
entonces
tengo aquí que bueno sé que mi velocidad
final está es igual a cero entonces aquí
lo que tengo es que mi cambio en la
velocidad
es igual a menos mi velocidad inicial
y de la fórmula de la aceleración que
hemos visto en vídeos anteriores sabemos
que el cambio voy a ponerlo en el color
el cambio en la velocidad
va a ser igual
la aceleración de la gravedad que en
este caso la aceleración gravitatoria es
d
- 9.8 y puse metros al cuadrado porque
esa aceleración metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado multiplicado por el cambio en
el tiempo
por el cambio en el tiempo y aquí el
cambio en el tiempo se trata de el
cambio en el tiempo para subir para
llegar a mi velocidad final de cero
entonces es este valor
de 2.5 segundos este segundo se cancela
con uno de los segundos de aquí y me el
resultado del cambio de velocidad
vamos a usar nuestra poderosa cálculo
y vamos a usar ahora multiplicar
este
92 puntos 19.8 punto 8 por 2 puntos 5
y nos queda menos 24.5
- 24.5 metros sobre segundo
esa es la velocidad inicial ya que
tenemos que en nuestro cambio de
velocidad es igual a menos mi velocidad
inicial si esta es mi cambio de
velocidad entonces
mi velocidad inicial
es igual
menos
y cambio de velocidad que es igual a
menos menos 24.5 metros sobre segundo
menos por menos da más entonces mi
velocidad inicial es igual a 24.5 metros
sobre segundo esta es la velocidad con
la que lancé la pelota para que pudiera
mantenerse todo ese tiempo en el aire
entonces así eres simples que pudimos
calcular la velocidad inicial el tiempo
total lo dividimos entre 2 y lo
multiplicamos para hacer los cálculos y
así obtenemos la velocidad inicial y así
es como hemos calculado la primera parte
de este problema otra parte que me
interesa saber es cuál fue el
desplazamiento o la distancia que
recorrió esta pelota este durante el
tiempo que estuvo en el aire quiero
saber el desplazamiento la altura hasta
qué distancia llegó hacia arriba la
pelota cuando la lance a esta velocidad
entonces ahora vamos a trabajar con la
fórmula del desplazamiento la fórmula
del desplazamiento nos dice que es este
desplazamiento es igual a la velocidad
promedio
velocidad promedio
multiplicado por la diferencia en el
tiempo
una forma de calcular la velocidad
promedio
siempre que tengamos sí y sólo si
tenemos una aceleración constante y aquí
como estamos trabajando con la
aceleración de la gravedad terrestre es
una aceleración constante nunca cambia
entonces bueno puedo usar esta velocidad
promedio como esta fórmula la velocidad
final
más la velocidad inicial
todo esto dividido
entre 2
entonces bueno ponemos tengo mi
velocidad final mi velocidad final sé
que es un
es un cero ya tengo mi velocidad inicial
que es de 24.5 entonces mi velocidad
promedio es igual a 24.5 entre 2
y esto resulta ser 24.5 entre 2
12.25
metros sobre segundo es mi velocidad
promedio entonces ya tengo este dato
para calcular
la distancia o perdón el desplazamiento
porque estamos hablando de vectores es
igual a mi velocidad promedio
12.25
metros sobre segundo multiplicado por el
espacio de tiempo como estamos viendo
hasta el momento que el aparato llegó a
su altura máxima recordamos que este
periodo de tiempo es la mitad del tiempo
total entonces está del tate es igual
2.5 segundos estos segundos se anulan y
el resultado del desplazamiento
12.25
x 2.5 este es igual a 30.625 30.625
metros de desplazamiento esto es la
altura que alcanzó la pelota que es algo
pues bastante impresionante creo que es
bueno no sé si existe alguna persona que
pueda lanzar una pelota a esta altura es
más o menos la altura de un edificio de
nueve pisos y espero que hayan
encontrado divertido este vídeo y a lo
mejor pueden ustedes jugarlo alguna vez
para entretenerse en una tarde de ocio